each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so delighted to have a dragon who's
from none of the institution's listed on
this thing but who's here for a couple
of days is gonna give a talk today on
ladee spacecraft ography and I'm glad to
see so many of you here tomorrow is
giving another talk at the same time in
the same room but those of you on that
side of the room may not be able to hear
it because there'll be a barrier in
between so and for those of you who are
but it really needs no introduction here
rice worked on a variety of topics and
tomorrow's will be completely different
from today's but tomorrow is some of her
work with with Thomas vidicon according
the key equality is SDP probably
different audience connection s so it
has a wide spectrum
okay thank you my thanks for the
invitation so um I thought the pen for
today's to give confirm very high-level
overview of this area there won't be
much many technical details and feel
free to interrupt me so I just want to
give you kind of an overview of this of
this area and I'll start with very short
introduction and the second part of the
talk should serve some kind of warm up
it's something I think you just I want
you to this is something nice and later
you can tell your friends about and then
we go to the main part of the talk and
this will be about lettuce base crypto
so so I should start by saying what what
lettuces are all about and why we care
about them so this is a this is a kind
of my attempt to
render two-dimensional lattice this lets
a set of points with periodic like
structure it's a mathematical object
geometrical object and more formally
it's defined in this way you take n
linearly independent vectors V 1 up to
VN in n dimensional space and you just
take all their integer combinations so
it's a bit like linear span except you
take integer combinations and not just
integer combinations okay so there's the
picture of it there shows a small part
of a lattice right as you can imagine it
goes in you know in all directions to
infinity I take two vectors V 1 V 2 and
then take all the combinations you know
twice V 1 V 1 plus V 2 and so on and so
forth so you know this seems like a
natural thing to look at it has
mentioned later lots of properties you
see this during this talk v1 up to VN I
would call these vectors the basis of of
a lattice this is two dimensional
lattice in general we care about higher
dimensions like say 500 dimensional
lattices this is this is the range that
we interested in usually for for crypto
ok so what's what's what's interesting
about this lattices is that there
our enemy
and is equal to n in the sense anything
with it don't need that you can consider
what's known as non full rank but it
doesn't add very much in reality so an
equal zhenya so the basis is not unique
this is what make this what makes this
so interesting for computational
purposes you could generate the same the
same that is ahead before actually you
can generate it in two ways you can
generate in many ways but it is in these
two ways you can take either v1 prime v2
prime which is the way you would anyway
we would expect to generate this lattice
but you can also take a different basis
you can take v1 v2 which is kind of much
closer together and the reason I
generate the same that is because you
have constellations you can take in this
case you know three times v2 and
subtract four times v1 and you know you
can see it generates here it generates
this vector so if you add and subtract
you end up with the same short vectors
as before like v2 prime p1 prime so in
short a lots of basis for a lattice and
this is kind of crucial this what makes
it hard for for computation and this is
what makes it useful for crypto
applications so the history is quite old
actually dating back to the early 19th
century work by Gauss actually gave
already given algorithm one of the
earliest algorithms for for solving
certain methods problem in two
dimensions this is the Gauss's algorithm
from 1801 later worked by her meat and
Minkowski and it's a nice area they look
a bit unhappy all these mathematicians
but nice area to work in I think it's
because of the way the probabilistic
method this yeah you can yeah don't know
if he formulated this way but true this
proof you need look at the happiness
support three
so there's there's lots of those been
lots of working this today their
interest is actually different it comes
from number theory applications will
actually care about other slightly other
aspects
maybe Gauss is the closest to us one
thing I have to mention because any talk
on on lattices I wanted to mention this
this is the celebrated Elliott algorithm
it's not something he had even happier
lonely faculty I don't know if this is
something I don't I won't use it in the
talk but that's something I have to say
this is algorithm very famous algorithm
by Leinster Lindstrand lavas in 1982
what it does is essentially you know you
input the input this is that lattice in
the form of n basis vectors and and what
it does it finds somewhat short vectors
in this lattice somewhat short is
actually not so sure this actually
exponentially long in the dimension but
still for many applications is a great
algorithm it has lots of applications in
many different areas so it's for
instance you can and this was the
original application you can factor
polynomials say over the integers you
can solve integer programs in if you
have integer program in fixed dimension
this is through such algorithms this is
how one solves them so it's a new
integer program involving only a small
number of variables but still numbers
might be big in the integer program it's
not you know a priori obvious how to
solve such things and this is how this
is how it's usually done another cute
application you know related the first
bullet there is what's known as finding
integer relation so I give you a number
so you do some experiment right you do
some numerical integrals have you get
this number six point seven three two
zero five zero eight and you wondering
maybe tonight's number maybe it's you
know square root of 17 plus five to the
power one-third some nice algebraic
number does anyone know does this ring a
bell but the petitions here that might
something stupid say it's yes
right so it's five plus three this was
an easy one but you can do any any
algebraic number this is the degree to
but you can do higher degree algebraic
numbers and it data finds it so you can
do any math like in maple mathematica
you can give this approximation of the
brag number and spits out this number
it was the minimum and the way you do it
you can take the powers of number and
take integer combinations and more
related to our work it's been used
during the 80s for attacking crypto
system based on knapsack and in certain
variants of the RSA cryptosystem you
know some very special cases of our say
it's a very nice work and kind of leads
us towards the topic of today's talk
yeah which we which one is guess the
right one is one of the lens for us
probably are en Linea yeah okay so one
one problem just to give you a flavor of
the kind of computation problems we care
about one of the prototypical problems
is known as the closest vector problem
so the input is again a lattice in a
form of n linearly independent vectors
in this case two vectors b1 b2 but you
also give it the addition you're given a
point in space not part of the lattice
at point you and your goal is to find
the nearest lattice point so think of
you as being close I want to find that
you know that point next to you how do
you do that this is the closest vector
problem and in general it's a hard
problem it seems very difficult the best
known algorithm to take time
exponentially in the dimension so if we
in dimension if I found that it seems
extremely difficult but one observation
exercise if the point you happens to be
inside the lattice you can you can tell
that inside lattice you can you can
detect this anyone see how easy you
essentially a you can invert the matrix
or just solve for the coefficients of U
in the basis B I go see an elimination
just and see if the whole integer
express you in the basis B R and C for
the coefficients are integers this is if
and only if u is part of the lattice and
some of the difficulty here is that U is
not quite there and because the vectors
B are so long even though you is close
you know the coefficients all get messed
up and you won't see much so just a
flavor of why this is a hard problem yet
in the mid-80s bubble I suggested an
algorithm sometimes works and the
algorithm does the following thing
assume you have a basis and if the basis
is nice the algorithm works well if the
basis is not nice the algorithm doesn't
work so well and the idea is extremely
simple essentially what we said before
if I have a point I just write a point
in the in this basis and and round each
coefficient to the nearest integer so I
just Express the point in my basis you
know if I see 0.9 I just run this to one
if I see 5.2 I run this five and if you
think about what it essentially does is
something like this it program partition
the space you know this is what we call
parallelepiped
there's a kind of linear transformation
of boxes and each into each area like
this is mapped to the point in between
so in this case it does a pretty good
job this algorithm because you see you
know all the point here a map to the
pole new center and it kind of its kind
of right it's not exactly right actually
point here closer to this one but it's
pretty good but this is only if you have
a good basis if you have a bad basis
like this picture looks very different
it's actually very bad algorithm because
points that are here are still going to
map all the way here and this can very
bad because you're actually very close
to the guy here you're gonna map there
so you know just it's something I hope
is give you some intuition of why this
problem is hard okay so now this is the
warm up I won't give too many details
about it's just something that you can
one little thing you can take from this
talk so there's something called the g
GH digital signature scheme it was one i
would say one of the early attempts to
use that this is for crypto what you are
sure today is actually that it had a
serious flaw and i'll show you how to
break it one reason I want to emphasize
why there was this flaws because there
was no security proof I mean there was
this construction that seemed to make
sense it seemed to be secure you know
but after
you know after some time turned out that
this is this is actually can be broken
I'll say more about this later on but so
once we get to the main part of the talk
I'll show you that our constructions
with the security proof that shows us
that it is
Tellem or I'll tell you more about this
later the idea it's very elegant very
beautiful idea
it actually was used later to construct
a secure system the idea was as we saw
before CVP is hard but if you have a
good basis if you are lucky to have this
good basis you can actually solve it
pretty well and this was the idea behind
the signature scheme so I want you know
I want to assume and you know anything
about crypto I want to assume we know
but exactly how do you define a
signature scheme I'll mention later what
what is really amounts to this later
this proposal of ggh was later taken and
using a brilliant construction that came
from this mathematician from how grave
Graham Piper Silverman and white part of
the intro company the they managed to
get a very concrete implementation of
this based on very nice ideas from from
algebra and managed to get very concrete
nice parameters with signatures of
length only less than 2,000 bits this is
quite quite important for application of
signature scheme if you want to put this
a smart card or something like that
and the signing verification extremely
fast a fasten our say based method it
seemed very promising and you know there
was I Triple E group try to standardize
this so there was lots of nice activity
around this and let me show the idea
around the you know behind this ggh
signature scheme so so what is the
signature scheme you have some kind of
information some message you want to
sign you know imagine Microsoft wants to
release some update this is one so sinus
is authentic and the way you would do
this you would select you know it's
Microsoft if my own private key I store
this privately no one knows this and the
private key is essentially just a good
basis I choose some somehow I'm not
telling you how but you somehow choose a
good basis I'm also normal like vectors
and what a releases the public is
another basis
a bad one I perturb it somehow I take
very long vectors okay does that way to
do it I won't tell you how but there
ways to release a very bad basis
associated with this private this is not
where the trouble lies okay and the idea
is the following I think of my message
my my the file I want to distribute my
email I think of it as a point in space
but a standard ways of mapping a file
into a point in n-dimensional space this
is not so important for us just think of
the message being just some random point
in space and the way I want to sign this
message is by simply by outputting a
near lattice point so my signature that
I'm going to attach the message is
simply a nearby lattice point and me as
Microsoft I can do this because I have
the private key and I can run the
buh-bye algorithm I can just round the
coefficients and I get this nearby
lattice point so that's what I'm going
to release each time I have a message
I'm releasing a signature which is
nearby lattice point now with you know
some of the clients don't see they see
don't see the private key they only see
the public key but they can still verify
this that they see okay here's the
message here's the file I was I just
received that's where it sits in a space
and here is a signature I all I have to
do I have to check two things I have to
check first that the signature is really
a lattice point but that's easy I just
we do this before right we just compute
the coefficient C double integer and
then I measure the distance I subtracted
two vectors and look at the norm you
know left to be nearby
very easy and seems to make sense it's
definitely correct the only question is
whether it's secure questions is this
clear okay good so
so what we show this there's actually an
inherent security flaw here in the
tournament where where it lies and we if
we implemented this it was actually some
fatty fur
first and last time had a chance to
implement something and I think both and
we only needed 400 signatures to recover
the entire secret key it was actually
surprisingly efficient we didn't expect
it to be so fast and so efficient so
after after receiving 400 signatures
using this enter sign proposal you can
just get the whole secret key and it was
extremely fast took a couple of minutes
and it was for three four years ago so I
guess today would be even faster right
entering a simple essentially you know
for for our purposes just ugh but it's a
very clever implementation of DGA it
makes it so efficient and so important
because of the size in size of the
signatures it's very small they use
essentially cyclic stick if you like
lattices to reduce the size of things
because the GGH originally is quite
wasteful so here so so signatures are so
I assume after seeing for her that's
updates each sign separately I can tell
you what the secret key is right so I
need I need some features okay so a
signature scheme given and should be
able to do the following you have if a
way to choose a private key you keep
privately and you release a public key
and what you're supposed to be able to
do with it is give it any file you're
supposed to compute something based on
your private key subject when you
release this anyone can tell right this
is signed by you I know and no one
should be able to forge this so what
we're doing here essentially not only
forging signatures but even worse we
extracting their private key it's kind
of worse possible way of attacking
forging is weaker attack you might be
able to force some messages not all of
them but basically you know attacking
you the private key and you can forge
anything later
I should if I knew you were there we
make more careful so you know made a
point of sitting there
see
so we're thinking this is a good picture
security perfect
this is happy and I mean story there
yeah turned out to be okay so is here
how it how it works and the the the idea
is this right this is what Microsoft has
this is private key it allows no
Microsoft to sign messages but I don't
see it right I only see this I only see
a message and a signature so I see it
some random point in space and I see the
nearby lattice point so what I want to
do with this I just you know I just put
it aside now I see another one another
update comes these days is kind of every
day I get an update from Microsoft so no
offense and then I just put it aside I
do it again and now the update comes a
blue decide another update comes put
aside let me know when you see a pattern
so after you do it a couple of times so
you see a shape and the shape is exactly
the shape of that parallelepiped that is
hidden you know by the private key so
this is this is the main observation
that you know once you collect enough
signatures and take the difference
between a signature in the message you
essentially get points sample uniformly
from the secret shape the shape is
secret you're not supposed to know it
the blue thing is the this signature it
doesn't really matter you
yellow isms message' the signature yes
so each time there's a new message
coming okay right and so message to lick
up the Serrano point space usually new
hash you have a fight and you hash it
into space and usually it results I
don't need to assume anything it just
comes a new update a new randomly
generated message I don't assume
anything about the message I just need
to assume that this sufficient Union for
me distributed but usually that's the
case because you apply some hash
function okay so then what you end up
with is this question right you're
supposed to solve the following
statistical equation so we have a bunch
of points sampled from n dimensional
parallel pipe it so in two dimensions
it's a parallelogram and you have you
know it is a sample there you have all
this point sample from it and you know
how do you recover the parallelepiped
and you know this is in two dimensions
in three dimensions looks like this so
this would be well if you can see
anything if you don't see actually it's
good because it shows that it's
non-trivial but you could actually do it
we given points in our case it was like
in 500 dimensions you can extract the
shape of this so you can try to think
how to do this yeah there's some right
so this is somewhat of cheating because
it's a cyclic lattice 400 actually
translates to 400 times 500 so it's
slightly more dragging
so in the case of enter sign there's
some symmetry in the in the lights so
you know the shape has some symmetry if
a point if you once you get a point you
know also 500 other points also there so
you can use all of them yeah so this
this made it 400 and not 20000 okay so
I'm not going to tell you more about
because it's not really you just would
have had to wait for 20,000 samples with
the complexity of it yeah it might have
been the same
yeah actually first we didn't realize
the symmetry we just did with 20,000
samples and later these was white who
told us that actually you only need 400
you just use the symmetry it's in terms
of action in practice doesn't matter
much is fine well think of the number of
emails send by by you or any company
there lots of signatures hovering all
over the place so that's true 400 sounds
reasonable maybe between it tells
exactly less but it's not good in any
case for signature schemes to be broken
after 20000
it's 200,000 try to make it sound nicer
No
okay so the superb is actually happy
ending the idea nggh is a good idea and
this was actually made secure probably
secure by later paper using the ideas of
Chamonix
so there's currently the RFP will be
secure signatures it's by Gentry Pegg
peickert invite Kunta nut and but it's
not quite yet I would say as efficient
as what we had before but is it secure
okay so just kind of brings me to the
main part of this talk and this is kind
of more than that it's based crypto how
to do it in a provable way I should have
said this before but let me know if a
good time it's better to say it now than
ever
I'm cryptography is everywhere and we
really want to have cryptography uh
credit cards passports mobile phones and
no soo probably no no everyone is using
RSA these days and websites you know
almost all applications these days use
our say and kind of the goal of this
project is long term project is to can
find some alternatives to RSA and I'll
try to convince you that slowly getting
there maybe we already have no
reasonable alternative to our say so how
does this story start start in the mid
90s work by I tie and I tied work
give me seminal work they they made this
brilliant observation
it is realization that you can actually
use lattices to create crypto it wasn't
obvious until then I told you before
people use that is to break crippled use
things like ll algorithm to break you
know algorithmic tool to break certain
constructions and they said actually
let's construct that's create you know
let's create crypto system based on
analysis it has some amazing properties
which in only in the last few years we
fully understand some of this this
constructional II wasn't perceived as
something that can really lead to some
think useful or practical it was
extremely deficient I think if you
actually try to implement it you would
need keys of size some bytes and
of course it would be extremely slow
it's not only you know not only the
numbers are big it's also kind of
cumbersome to work with and seems very
difficult to extend I mean you do
something very specific but if you want
to do something slightly different and
if we have to redo the whole thing seem
to be of purely theoretical interest and
somewhat limited and I think more
recently they seem to seem to be a
change and kind of like this B script is
becoming more mainstream right this is a
great question are this promise really
hard and you know the same question have
about factoring and there's lots of work
in that and there's you know lots of
progress with things like number field
sieve highly non-trivial algorithms and
we'd say that for lattices they actually
there isn't much progress we have you
know we have a relatively seems to be
stable understanding of what one can do
and for many many years there hasn't
been I would say three decades there
hasn't been you know true progress I
mean the websites you can download
challenges like in five hundred
dimensions no one knows how to solve it
it seems like a really hard problem in
concrete you know size it straight face
in your question I mean you'll talk
about that I guess I mean it's not
you're not wrong in the worst case
complexity so
yes I mentioned if they obviously the
distributions are well understood this
is something to get to in a point where
to find hard instances and sometimes
that everywhere but you'll see you'll
see what I mean later so so so so more
recently what I'd like to talk about
today is a problem called learning with
errors problem and this problem somehow
abstracts the way the lattice and gives
you a very convenient very pleasant
thing to work with and this problem can
be shown to be as hard as a static
problem so this is kind of an
intermediary problem the problem is as
hard as lattice base status questions
but it's extremely useful for crypto
element you see what this problem is
about in a slide it's a very nice
problem to work with but kind of the
funny thing it kind of came from attempt
to attack all these letters both crypto
schemes using quantum computation you
see some of this later on but it's
actually the problem is itself is
nothing to do with quantum computation I
just want to mention the history of this
which might still play a role in the in
the future of this problem and this and
I think the scripta system is still the
only crypto system where ideas from
quantum computation play an important
crucial role even though the system you
see it's not there's nothing quantum
about it it's kind of behind the scenes
but it's it's it plays a very important
role which is I think it's still not
fully understood so what what's so good
about this why why bother about this we
have our say everything is good with our
say why bother with other alternatives
so try to give you four reasons why it's
how they're better faster and stronger
so next I'll be harder
it's provably secure based in the worst
case problem so this is something I
guess I can spend 10 slides on I won't
do it here the idea is that when you
take something like RSA and you break
our say what you managed to do is
factors say not even that but say I
managed to factorize certain number what
happens here is that once you break
these schemes
actually managed to break all instances
of this lattice problem not just a
specific one but actually all the
instances of the lattice problem this
there's some random self random property
of this lattices that once you solve one
of them you solve all of them it's a
it's it's unique to this this kind of
systems in this in this very strong form
it's a very nice security property you
kind of tells you that it removes some
parameters from the scheme like when you
run our say you have to start thinking
we know how to choose the P and the Q
know should they be you know like one
model for three model for and so on so
forth here you don't have that ambiguity
and the parameters are determined kind
of clear everything has to be you know
everything is already specified in some
sense and once once you break the scheme
with the parameters I give you you know
you merely solve all instances of
forgiven or all instances of the status
problem so like this is something a bit
delicate to explain in such a short time
but I hope you get to leave some sense
of what's what's in it good if you care
about it you can ask it I'm happy to get
questions on this okay so so the second
thing which some might dismiss as
irrelevant but I actually I would
contend that it is relevant so far these
things are resistant to quantum
computers and you know in contrast our
say and everything based on number
theoretic assumptions is broken by
quantum computers so you might say not
point of computers but you know how sure
are you in ten years there won't be any
quantum computers and you know I really
willing to take the chance that in 10
years there won't be any public key
crypto there won't be any cryptography
this is just a new story from new york
times like two months ago three months
ago
no IBM claiming they already essentially
have a quantum computer I think this
bits of overhyping here but they seem
optimistic saying that it's no longer 50
years away it's only 15 years away
I wish I wish its yeah but I think
they're doing the going in the right
direction not trying to factor bigger
the big numbers but actually trying to
come up with a scalable design once you
have it that you should be able to scale
it to bigger and bigger sizes but in any
case I think it's you know it's
something humanity should have an
alternative and maybe this is this is
maybe one way to go so so far it seems
to listen to point the computer despite
my attempts to break it and the third
thing it is in some cases these things
can be faster than other other
constructions like like our say I should
be carefully ours is extremely fast the
advantage here is that there are no
exponentiation needed I'll show later
what goes into this schema but
essentially just addition and
multiplication basic multiplication so
it might be in some applications for
some application faster and this the
last thing in last but not least
actually think it's very nice very
important thing is that this is only
something realized in the last two years
I'll talk about later you can do more
things you can do things we just didn't
know how to do before using anything
number theoretic crypto and specifically
I'm referring here to this latest
breakthrough on fully homomorphic
encryption I'll talk about this at the
end this is something that so far we
essentially only know how to do based on
on lattices and based on this lwe
problem okay so the questions so far
before we get okay so yeah here's the
one way to describe the lwe problem it's
all the way it's usually described this
is the way you can have a nice take-home
message you can keep it you know keep
this picture in mind this is good
actually usually it's a slightly
different form but let me describe this
anyway because I think it's cute so you
know I give you a sequence of numbers as
many as you wish you can give you two
billion numbers and I tell you say
either numbers are just uniform in the
interval 0 1 or there's actually there
there's some close to some one over s
for some number it's so actually that
close to some actually disappear in this
case period of seven in this picture
with our close to to that period with
one over seven so example there on top
0.154 and so and so forth
does anyone see is this do you see any
structure in these numbers does it look
like it comes from something like that
close to some so it's the only actually
very close to one over thirteen so I
chose 13 so you won't immediately see
that but it's so if it's so hard with 13
you can imagine what happens we take a
bigger number and this is essentially
they add one version of the LW program
so you can add several ways to phrase it
one way would be like we asked you to
find s so there's you know you can think
of you couldn't think of it in the
following way I just give you a sequence
of numbers AI and I tell you that
there's some number s in this case 13
such as AI times s is close to 0 modulo
1 ok and you're supposed to either tell
me that the recession s meaning it's not
just a bunch of uniform numbers or tell
me what s is in unhappy either way it's
essentially the problem this seems to be
hard I'll tell you later what we know
about the hardness of this problem and
we also tell you that the way it's
usually stated this is the well using
this talk it's usually stated in the
n-dimensional way two things are
essentially equivalent this for this
talk and the way it's usually stated
there's also some secret period but we
prefer to work with zq to the end
so there's vectors n dimensional vectors
with numbers model q that's the way
usually it's presented and the way it's
presented is that usually there's there
would be some secret s secret s is now n
numbers mod look you and what you're
given is like approximate equations like
that i'm telling you i take some uniform
coefficients AI until you either product
of AI times s is
essentially bi or equivalently once a
subtract some number bi is close to zero
so essentially I give you all these
linear forms and tell you I give you the
a I give it a B I don't give you the S
but so you get all these lists of
equations and tell you you know the
approximately correct okay just tell me
what s is no can you recover it from
here maybe now it's a good time to say
why why is there this approximate where
is there this noise in equations if
there's no noise then it's easy to solve
right if there's no such a give you a
bunch of equations you can recover its
right you just do some kind of some
Gaussian elimination you will cover it
from equations we know how to solve
equations the reason it's not trivial is
because of this noise right once you try
to do anything with this that Gaussian
elimination you have to combine equation
then the noise starts you're messing
everything up
you could probably yeah then you can
take yeah I don't even live in Tabriz
you could take take a prime take
everything multi prime factor Q I just
won't say to tell this apart from
uniformed
yeah QA q small you should accuse for no
melanin my factoring is easy right you
have quantum computers then oh you have
you solved it no it's integers but you
have to be a bit careful you can do it
over the integers but you have to be
careful it's definitely cleaner when
everything is modeled q it's because
it's just yeah I mean if you just just
completely just remove the module here
you think it's it's gonna be easy mmm
you can tell something it's very big
right but but but that's in ways to
define without the model it makes sense
I can think about it's like you yeah one
of the things about is it's so versatile
so usually unless you do something very
bad you can define lots of variants of
this and they all be secure so what do
we know about security of this that
actually two main statements and the
first one which I would say this is
unfortunately still the only true
security statement that we have is the
following it says that this problem W is
essentially as hard as you know n
dimensional lattice problems are not
being precise here but essentially as
hard as what's known as the shortest
vector problem the details don't matter
but essentially as hard as the worst
case instances of these problems what
this means is if you break the problem
this L debris problem if you break it
you even with some small percent some
small probability like 1% you managed to
find this then you immediately get the
solution for all lattice instances okay
not just a specific one not related to
that the specific L debris instance you
have you made the gate solution to all
the worst case in all instances of l w
which is a very nice very strong
statement the only caveat which is
unfortunately big a bit here is that
this this reduction is a quantum
reduction what this means is that if you
break
lwe but the theorem tells you is there
is an algorithm for break
for solving that this problems but this
is it is a quantum algorithm so if you
think about it actually makes the
segment weaker because we would like to
have the conclusion you know classical
algorithm for solving lattices but we
get a weaker conclusion we get only
quantum algorithm for solving it which
way makes it less more suspicious I mean
is it really secure under quantum for
quantum algorithms we believe it is so
far there hasn't been any progress has
told you before these questions seem to
be secure but you know I would really
like to get rid of this quantum thing
unfortunately we don't know how to do it
it seems crucial in all these
constructions luckily there is a way
around it I mentioned he rots of works
more maybe the the most relevant are the
recent works by Chris peickert from 2009
and mostly work with the black hairs key
language delay and the peickert based on
gold basically I could vacuum tonight on
and essentially what what what this says
it says ok you can make it a classical
reduction but then you need to do the
square in the dimension so you can say
that with some caveats that LW of size n
is as hard as worse-case squared and
dimensional like these questions ok
usually reductions so this tells us that
no at least even if quantum algorithms
no break lwe then not all is lost we
still know that LW of size n is as hard
as square root and dimensional lattice
questions it's not as nice I mean we'd
have to work with bigger bigger size LW
but it's something you know we have
something to work with so you know these
are kind the two main statements that
ideally I would like to have something
like the first statement without the
quantum part unfortunately we're not
there yet
it's a big mystery I mean this has been
open for many years and I really don't
know how to explain this
there are several ways to interpret
what's going on here so just so I won't
show the proof I want to move on to
applications I should show it this year
so once how these things are used but
some of the ideas that go into all these
proofs are things like blurring in
lattice so you take if you take a
lattice and Gaussian noise you see what
happens here is that slowly this this
Gaussian noise increased since some
point becomes completely essentially
flat essentially completely white it's
not really flat
but it's it's essentially so close to
flat that you can see it it's actually
becomes all white should I show another
example here I start with with certain
two-dimensional lattice and I add
Gaussian noise slowly this things
increase Chris even more and at some
point just become so close this is real
simulation and it's just so close to fly
that you don't see anymore a difference
this essentially this is this property
is what makes all that this is the same
I mentioned before that if you break one
you break all this is kind of what's
causing it that after you add enough
noise is really not there's no
difference left between one that is any
other that is but but of course there's
much more to the proof than this but
this is this this is one idea that it
goes in there okay so so recently
there's been lots of work on this this
is something I stole from Chris bikers
and the amount of papers the number of
papers on nwe and here is a list there's
been lots of working crypto especially
lots of application you take this a
debris problem which is seems like a
clean enough program it's very versatile
you can do tons of things with it you
can do normal public key encryption CC a
secure for those of you we know what it
says identity based encryption and lots
of lots of other things I'll tell you
today about two things just the basic
public encryption and try to tell you a
bit about this newest and coolest thing
the fully homomorphic encryption this
work of Gentry and others let's see how
far we get just to give you some sense
of how one works with this l.w program
it just is so convenient to work with it
I think it's nice if you see it so
here's how to create a public key
encryption scheme to just to recall if
you've never seen public encryptions the
idea again i have a way to choose a
private key a public key I release the
public key you know anyone else should
be able using the public key send an
encrypted messages to me and I should be
able to recover them using my private
key okay so it's extremely simple you
just choose a random essence L key to
the end this is my private key I keep it
secret normally as we see it and the
public key is you know all these pairs
AI bi and they are representing
equations AIS
USB is essentially zero with some with
some noise and noises is even noise okay
the noise is an even number this is okay
can you assume they know it's some small
even number so essentially what I'm
releasing at the public key is at least
long enough list of such approximate
equations I tell you that I give you a
IBS I tell you a is essentially bi up to
some even noise why is this useful so
here's here's how you know you as a
person receiving the public key can send
me an cryptic messages I think we just
want to send me a bit you want to tell
me just one bit of message okay you can
easily repeat this and send more bit so
what you do you take all this
approximate equations that I sent you
and then you just take a subset of them
a random subset of them and just you
know sum them up so you have you know
you take you know a - s - B - you know
itself is 0 you know a 7 s + - b 7 f is
you just sum up this random subset of
equations and you end up with something
like this here the sum of s AI and sum
of SBI and I want you to add the bit x0
1 to the right hand side and why is that
if you think of what I said she did here
but if you sum up equations that are all
approximately correct up to some even
error sum is also approximately correct
it's some small even number the
right-hand side if I add X if I add 1
then suddenly the error becomes odd and
not even and that that's that's why I
can either decode it so here's how we
decode it I will decrypt and I'm
receiving you send me now this
encryption you send me this pair a and B
and all I have to do is I know s right I
know the secret key i compute the inner
product of a and s I subtract the B and
I see just if it's even all I take I
take a very modular - that's all
hey is this right this is the encryption
of the first component in the encryption
pair it's not since capital is not
saying otherwise it would not be secure
so maybe the way to think of it is that
the publicly consists of all this
approximate equations AI times s is
roughly bi up to even oiz you want to
encrypt you just take a subset of them
sum them up you get another equation
that's also approximately correct up to
some even noise and you send me that
equation either as is or by adding one
to the right hand side right and and I
can plug in it and I see the two things
are close but either even distance apart
or distance apart and I can therefore
tell if you encrypt x0 1 this make sense
those of you who seen before I'm worthy
writing in a slightly different way
because I'm planning to use it later for
the fully homework encryption
so alpha zero means that this actually
it's a small even number this is the
noise so it's actually the equations I
release are never accurate equation
otherwise it would be easy it won't be
secure so small even number it actually
to be precise you have to chose it from
some typically some normal distribution
but it should be in this case should be
even
right so I you need in this specific
implementation it's not the most
efficient way to do it but here you need
n log Q pairs so the size of the public
key is n log Q times another end okay I
would say for H equations like N squared
essentially N squared bit it's not the
most efficient way of doing things so
let's just see the decryption is is like
that and correctness essentially we
argued or Adi correctness why this is
correct decryption the security for
mainly for the experts the way to prove
security is in two steps first you say
that by the hardest proof of hardest
sumption lwe we know that the public key
this list of approximate equation just
looks like a uniform random numbers if
there's no structure it can be lean from
the a and B I just a bunch of random
numbers so you might as well replace
them in the num numbers and then the
second part says that if AI and bi
really random numbers when you sum up n
log Q of them that's why I need n oq of
them when you sum up a subset of size n
oq of them you essentially get uniform
junk you get uniform number
hence this X is completely hidden there
for those of you seen security proof
this should ring a bell it's the two
steps insecurity provides quite it's a
simple security proof you just do it
first apply the lwe assumption that AI
bi completely uniform no one can tell
the difference now it looks like a
uniform junk and then say that once a
uniform there's really nothing encoded
into any encryptions okay so here's the
second and last application I just I
think it's it's very nice later it was
recently it was headlines this is work
and fully homomorphic encryption which
allows to do this following almost
unbelievable thing you can send a
information to a server say like
Microsoft Azure or some other cloud
server and they do the computation for
you on your data and they send you back
the result without ever seeing your data
so you have an encrypted information you
don't send the secret key to to the
to the cloud they do the computation for
you and send you back the information
some applications of this the several
ways to motivate this assume you use
some secret information and you don't
want to believe this but you also don't
want to spend time computing it like you
want to compute something on some DNA do
some analyses on the patient you have
some DNA information you want to do some
computation if you don't have the means
to build a computation but you also
don't want to release that kind of
private information so you just send an
encryption of this DNA some computer in
the cloud can start processing it
computing something about DNA but you
know some risk of disease and send you
back the result but the cloud never sees
information cloud never knows what you
know what computation on what a
computation acts it's kind of
counterintuitive things seems almost
impossible actually for when it was
first suggested I believe it was
conjectured to be impossible but some
turns out this is this is possible and
this was done the first breakthrough was
by Craig Gentry in 2009 and listen did
his work by Bukowski by Kunta nut and
using essentially using EE in things I
showed you here and this is this is at
least this is very nice in theory still
it's very far from practice I mean these
things are horrendously inefficient so
the the amount of computation the cloud
would have to do is so much bigger than
just the ratio between what you have to
do normally in what the cloud would have
to do is really big but this is a
principle there this this thing is
possible and and there's a hope within a
couple of years maybe that the theory
will advance if we can actually do it
no there's still still into some
annoying part still yeah essentially the
cyclic there's some cyclic security
assumption that the main the missing
link but that's only one right okay okay
so let me try to show you how we do this
magic it's slightly I won't show you all
the details but just to show you how we
start doing it and in some sense the
first part I show you is very basic and
and you might know people knew this ten
years ago but somehow the most of the
magic will happen the second part you
see what I mean so okay so here's how we
start you all have this DNA you want to
send to server to cloud to do the
computation for you you choose a secret
key and as before the secret key is
simply a vector and n dimensional vector
with numbers modulo Q very simple so now
I have my data my DNA you know x1 up to
X n n bit string and I want to send it
to a server so I send encryptions of
these bits to the server and the way I
would do it similarly to what we did
before except we don't need all this
summing up equation stuff because this
is secret key setting so I would just
send n equations so for each bit I would
encode it in in the following way I
would take I would choose randomly you
know AI and I would would construct the
equation AI times s minus bi is
essentially zero and the noise will be
either even or odd based on the bit so
let me say this again I have my sequence
of bits for each bit I do the following
thing s is fixed I choose AI uniformly
is chosen uniformly and I just take the
inner product of air and s and I choose
bi so that AI times s minus bi is close
to zero but with some noise I'm not
going to make it exactly zero otherwise
it's easy to break so I'll add some
noise and the noise will be either even
odd based on my bit so software this is
just plain encryption let's see what the
server the cloud can do with this
information so the cloud just gets to
see AI and bi right SS hidden but it
gets all this AR s and V ice so one
thing the cloud can do this
this is the easy part the cloud can
easily ex orbit can add bits moderate to
so how do you do that you know I have a
of this linear equation a times s minus
B I've been a four minus a times s minus
B and have eight prime times s minus B
Prime
so and each one called the bit meaning
each one evaluates with their small even
numbers more odd number depending on the
bit all I do I just add them up so I add
up the two things I get a new linear
form I get a plus a prime times s minus
B plus B Prime and you'll notice that if
both have even always and I end up with
even always right if one is odd one is
even and up with odd noise and if both
are all the end up with even though in
other words X okay we did we mention do
X or of the secret bit without ever
seeing the secret information right so
this is this is the first part this is
the additive part of this of this scheme
which is it's always the easy part
the magic happens in the second part so
once we know how to add things motor -
how do we multiply things motor - how do
we do end we end to the end of two bits
once we do addition and an end we can do
anything right the only question how to
get to the other to tell apart so let's
try let's try to multiply two bits so I
want to do an end of two bits so the
idea is this I just again have two
equations and they each are either a
small even number or small odd number
and I just multiply them so that once I
multiply them I'll get it small because
it's products are too small is still
small and it will be all definitely if
both are odd if one of them is even the
result is going to be even so in that
sense it's okay but the mess is going to
run right hand side so you know I have
this expression let's see what happens
if I expand it let's start with the easy
part so I have B times B prime this is
very good this was scalars so I have B
times B prime there the cross-arm is
also pretty good right I have you know a
in a product s times P Prime
pretty good right I still I can write it
there it's still some linear form on the
only s and the only annoying part is
kind of this
fired this is what happens when you
multiply any product s with a prime
inner product s okay the trouble here is
if you think of it so what is it inner
product it's simply sum of a is I and
this is sum of a prime jsj and you
multiply the 2 you get 4 IJ you get a I
a prime J sis J that's what's written
here so s is think of s well being some
kind of formal variable here the server
doesn't know what s is but always plays
with this formula variable so this is
just one way to write this expression
here using tensors if this is if this
helps s tensor twice is simply the N
squared dimensional vector for inner
products it's just a fancy way of
writing this but ok so it seems like
maybe we're done I mean we have a way to
it is this way it seems somewhat short
we have a way to write the product of
two things but if you think about think
about which we're cheating here actually
we didn't make any progress because the
what's written here is actually much
longer if pression right this all these
coefficients here AI AJ prime all this a
tensor a prime it's now I have to store
N squared coefficients I have to store
all the AI AJ prime so we multiply two
things sure the way the way to represent
them but it's actually a terrible
terribly long it's N squared bits long
instead of being an you might think so
what but you have to repeat you have to
multiply more things and Scott become 10
to the 4 you know and and to the 8 and
so on so it's it's exposed very fast you
will don't want is to happen don't want
it to keep exploding more anymore this
is where the trouble starts
so yeah increases the size of the
ciphertext and just ignore the comment
there and the solution this is that the
ingenious solution solution says that
maybe it's not so bad maybe the user I
can provide a server with some hints to
help the server
keep the calculation at bay I don't want
it to
server to have the calculation explode
what I'm doing and providing a server
with and this is the ingenious idea
encryptions of sis J using a new key
using a new key s prime so what this
actually means I have another key
another secret key s Prime and I don't
give I don't fitness server what s prime
is but what I do tell the server I third
a server you know here's AI J here's bij
some some numbers actually AJ is a
victory and it's not the server AJ times
in a protein s prime minus bij is
essentially this thing you're looking
you're looking for sis J okay so the
server doesn't know sis J the server
also doesn't know it's prime but but I
give the server this approximate
equation I thought the server now these
two things are approximately correct why
this is this is so useful is because now
the servers you know the server is stuck
with its term this term containing N
squared coefficients this the sum over i
j AI AJ prime sis J now the server can
replace each sis J by the corresponding
form AI J in the product s prime minus
bij and now if you think about this this
actually all collapses because this is
just in a part of s Prime with something
plus a scalar so this what's written on
the right hand side is again of size n
notifies N squared
trying to encode the information given
by a a prime a be a-prime b-prime right
product of the two so we took the two
things that are small either all the
even numbers we multiply them we get
another small number that's all the
phenomena both are old which is the end
functionality which is good but now the
original thing was a times s minus B was
order even now it's some other guy times
s prime which is a different variable
right at the end of the day the end of
the day the server sends you back this
you know is prime you can still compute
and see if the answer the DNA is
positive or negative
you can still compute you can decode at
the end the fact that you switched a key
to nucleus you still have the secret key
you can you can do it so you need
another another key is the prime right
unless you do what's called the simpler
trick and you encrypt s under itself
this is what you end up doing this is
what also we mentioned before this is
the extra security assumption that we
need here this is the only the only
thing that we don't know how to formally
argue with security we don't know how to
formally argue some point in to close
this circle otherwise you would have to
provide more and more and more which is
also okay I mean for many applications
like if you have a load F circuit you
can do it this way will tell me how to
take some secret which is some bit which
is stored relative to s Prime and
convert it to some secret relative to s
that what you saying
that's essentially what it does but it's
more it's more than this because I
provide you here not just with the I
could just do it for the sis and it will
allow you to convert from encryption
under s to encryption under its prime
but actually I provide you with more I
allow you to take quadratic things as
size J I essentially give you all the
products of the coordinates of s and
still you can convert it to something in
terms of the SI I should say just to
make sure because this wasn't in case it
wasn't clear if you expand this
expression you should see there's the S
Prime comes out and you get S prime
inner product with some fixed n
dimensional vector ok case it's not
obvious with all day this is here so how
do I do that so I know s is J right
I choose s prime uniformly meet me as
the user
I choose air journey for me then I
calibrate the bij to be close to a
science J know this so this this is
really scaler this is a number modulo Q
s prime is the N dimensional vector
model Q now I choose this uniformly and
I just have to choose a scalar here's
bij essentially you know this minus this
plus some business actually I'm cheating
here I won't give you more details but
actually what I wrote here is it's wrong
but it's fine
the trouble is that the things this is
approximately that but once you multiply
by AI and AJ these are big numbers
actually it is easy cute trick to go
around this problem but I think what I
showed you here is this does capture
most of the intuition a thing with these
constructions
she should also do the near terms to
move everything to ask Brian
so I didn't say anything about this shoe
I said small plus small is small but
other small is bigger than the former
small that you can do too many this is
the another big component I said nothing
about this is what Greg calls the
bootstrapping once you have a way to do
enough steps you can clean up everything
and restart the whole process because
there's there's trouble here that it
didn't always keeps growing you just at
some point shrink it and there's some
beautiful ideas also in that paper by
backers can invite continent and how to
shrink the noise or some very nice ways
of doing that you shrink the noise yeah
to a point so just a basic idea the
basic idea is just to divide everything
you have some models q and you want to
divide everything by 100 it seems like a
very naive way of doing it but this
seems to actually work so not define
that sense but actually think of the
zero up to Q minus ones being mapped to
zero up to P over 100 minus one kind of
shrink everything behind come round to
the nearest integer there are other ways
of understanding it but this is so I
think yeah you did the user but okay I
don't think I can go into the entire
construction but there are lots of
missing edges yeah okay so I just
mentioned what I said so far is
efficient but they're not most practical
and kind of recently we've been trying
to work on more practically any
practical things by using some algebraic
structures we call this ring lwe and
like all this fully o morph encryption
for instance works also in this
algebraic setting seems to make
everything much more efficient you can
use fast Fourier transform and
everything and shrinks and it seems to
be really practical for the first time
we're talking about kilobytes and not
megabytes it is some nice also lots of
several nice theoretical aspects but
somebody talk ok so let me start with
this one I mean so the as you mentioned
somewhere in between also that you know
and homomorphic encryption the big
challenge seems to be that the work done
by the server for every binary operation
is huge and is that is it really just
sort of for every operation it's scaling
large or is it sort of further
complications if I have to do you know n
operations in a circuit this is I will
do n times some fixed constant which
depends on the security oh good question
I think that's true I think it's count
each operation translate to something
which is big but it's not the scaling is
leaner is they do anything right
essentially encryption right but it's
scaling
what's important is in our principle if
I do for your more encryption you know
if I have n operations to do you know
the amount of work that servers do is
end time something it's not n square
during their ideas on how one can get
around that the men can you get around
any times something I mean what what
could you mean by saying well we want it
to be more efficient at the server side
yeah I mean there's the question was for
something right
Rippey it's it's how often you have to
currently we're kind of putting the
thread from too many directions there's
one thing it's one thing I'm more
familiar with a lot of aspects probably
that I'm not so familiar with but one
thing in this construction is not so
nice it requires you to work with some
super polynomial or things that are
relatively large parameters and that
would be nice to get rid off and I think
this also this makes them that the
practical parameters not so nice so this
is one place where efficiency would be
much nicer and so the third questions
that one could hope to improve that
would be to practical more practical
schemes so after this worker since the
Craig works or something according with
more bits with one exception
we still very useful I hope there'll be
next few years would be some significant
improvement
like for specific right I think that's
partly what they do like they consider
in specific tasks it's part of what they
do trying to understand what have
operations you can do like there's like
seemed seemed operation like single
instruction multiple aided I have to
work in parallel so for certain
operations they can do it more
efficiently
there's nothing to do but improve it
it's just linear so yeah I guess in
practice you can think of us improving
the constant but I think it's they allow
you to do operations like with the
security parameter it's gonna be quite
significant but we still know there are
things the only limitations currently
available are for very small scale
problem and still that the keys are huge
and the Safra decks are you do yeah but
there's hope
you can also talk about very soon the
hardness of like approximate linear
equation was over the real with no mods
actually I think this you can find this
you can show I think you can make okay
depending on what exactly you make so
the a ice I guess one thing one of them
can be made real but the other one
should still be screwed right so it's
not it's still problem this thing still
I think some discrete ins in there okay
we'd have to think about that
all right thanks